[Music]
what is up welcome to stick to football
live we're gonna have a fun show for you
all today welcome if you're a sticky or
if you're new we're happy to have you
here Matt mellow and counter Rogers
we're gonna play some games today fellas
cash or trash this is where I give you
guys the rumors that Scouts and general
managers are blowing my phone up with
and you get to say if I'm being lied to
or not or if you actually believe the
rumors that are coming out as the silly
season one week before the draft
I have imagery as I can see you can see
my phone right say he's cheating over
here and then because it is a draft
three week here at redraft week that's
how we say redraft week here at bleacher
report we're going to redraft some
superstars from previous drafts and I'm
gonna correct some of the problems that
my favorite team the San Francisco 49ers
made and then of course we're gonna end
it with draft on trap that's where you
can leave your questions right here in
the comment stream below 600 alive and
we will answer those questions at the
end of the show fellas I didn't want to
ask though what are you doing with that
stimulus money that you're getting did
you here's a lemon right we're about
$1,200 going I don't know if I'm allowed
to say it on the Bleacher Report app you
finally get that Josh on the tattoo nope
you can pay for my tattoo yes please do
Connor yeah yeah the stimulus money
I don't know TBD I don't think we could
say it on the show this time right not
for me don't get one so you guys enjoy
her money have fun with that but
remember to follow us in the Bleacher
Report app to stick to football stream
we did a mailbag yesterday got over 800
questions the three of us so just one
more way that you can interact with us
here at stick to football as we do get
prepared for the NFL Draft which is in
just one week but guys I do want to get
into the cash-for-trash rumors because
things are heating up as we get closer
to Thursday night one of the draft kicks
off and this is the time of year you
don't know who to believe or what to
believe and I've shared this story
before last year this time it's when
someone from the Giants said hey Daniel
jones go there with your mock draft I
didn't believe him so I didn't think
they were dumb enough to do that they
turned around they made Daniel Jones the
top 10 pick so sometimes even you hear
things and don't believe it but let's
kick it off here this year
the biggest one and we'll go to another
quarterback like Daniel Jones who was
the number two quarterback to last year
this guy Justin a herbert expected to be
the number two quarterback drafted by
the Miami Dolphins
Melo you get to go first year buddy cash
or trash on this one the more I hear it
the more I'm buying into this one I'm
going cash with this one I think that
the the rumors around to it in the hip
and the injuries and maybe even a failed
physical there's a lot going on and they
haven't really been able to double-check
it so I'm gonna go cash on this one I do
think we see the Dolphins take Justin
Herbert next Thursday guys I'm gonna
roll this one up and throw it in the
trash but I'm a little nervous that
comes draft night I'll be pulling it
right back out because when you look at
this the rumors have been circulating
around Herbert and the Dolphins now for
quite some time I just think we're gonna
see a situation where they played this
very correctly in a scenario where they
were not forced to trade up for two
Otunga by Louis so if two is sitting
there at five I think that's the
direction the Dolphins will ultimately
go but if there are health concerns that
we are not privy to you can definitely
see them going one more down the board
and taking Herbert but right now it's
gonna be trash for me I wish I had
dollar bills to throw up in the air when
I think something's cash I actually do
bill this money stimulus money there
goes it's in the air I actually do
believe this one I think is cash but
we've said before this could also be
like the best executed smokescreen this
is like two years deep on the inception
the Chris Greer is doing is Jim other
Miami Dolphins so it would not shock me
if it is a smokescreen but I'll tell you
everyone in the NFL right now believes
this it's not just coming out of Miami
it's you talk to people like Buffalo New
England who know that organizationally
but so it doesn't matter what I'm sure
Giants fans a year ago didn't believe
that Daniel Jones is gonna be the pick
either and it happened right so people
until the night of the draft didn't
believe us when we said Kyler Murray was
gonna be the first take so listen and
learn Twitter users right the second
rumor and this one I know is gonna get
my boys heated because this is a player
we actually disagree on a little bit
Florida cornerback CJ Henderson a
projected top ten picking guy something
we heard back in the Senior Bowl when
Atlanta Falcons GM Thomas Ginn metrof
was on this very program he said they
had picked 16 for now so you get a two
parter here does Henderson go in the top
ten guys and do the Falcons maybe trade
up to get him
one of these spots there's a lot of
smoke coming out about the Falcons maybe
trading up and I think we were able to
break that back in January for those of
you walk remember I'm gonna take I'm
gonna take cash on this one - I do think
that CJ Henderson if it's not the
Falcons it could be the Jaguars and
they're sitting there at number nine I
don't know if they'd let him pass I
really love CJ Henderson I've been
leading this case for a long time now
you can see him he can tackle but his
ball skills like we talked about the
other day are amazing he can get his
hands up there he can make plays I love
the way he scrapes through catches I
really like CJ Henderson and I think the
NFL starting to come around on him - I'm
saying cash I think we seem going to top
10 and I was very late to the CJ
Henderson party but I'm gonna go cashier
as well guys I think Henderson had a
really nice process I think listen do I
value him as a top 10 player I'm not
there just yet but when you look at it
felt like for a while he got one we
crammed one corner and then you get to
go to the combine the guy runs in the
four threes he's got great size I think
his mentality might be a little
different than the Florida DBS we've
seen bust over the years and that might
have separated him or at least pushed
him up as the NFL's solidified corner -
Matt I know you said there's been some
buzz some teams actually like them as
the best overall corner which is very
very interesting to me but I think the
most important takeaway here is I am
buying that CJ Henderson goes in the top
ten of this draft I really thought there
was gonna be a virtual fight over the
over the collar hearing between you two
but I'm happy this is a guy Melo was on
very early kind of like you said this is
the time of year where we're actually
home when we can get caught up well of
course we're home right now but you get
caught up on tape and you find guys that
maybe you like or dislike more than you
expected I'm going cash on this as well
it might not be the Falcons guys I think
the the Panthers could just stay at
seven interesting you lose James
Bradbury just draft CJ Henderson and
then we look at teams like the Jaguars
at nine you lose jaylen Rams you lose AJ
boy you have gigantic needs a corner and
we've talked about how there's so much
depth at wide receiver
well the Jags pick again at 20 so you
can just wait and get your receiver at
20 and get a player I believe is a
shutdown corner as to why I think we're
seeing CJ Henderson rise guys
you can play man coverage 439 at six
foot one is
ready to play in man coverage I think
that's already throw let's talk about
that do we do we think that Falcons can
even come up and have a chance to get
him because I really don't see the
window for that I'm sure gonna find what
the Falcons would give up to do this
because they is not a team that's loaded
with draft capital which way they did
this last year they they drafted a
center they traded up and then they got
Kayla McGarry to end around one we've
seen times dimitrov be a little crazy
before he'll mortgage the future to do
that I don't know that like you said
Connor I don't know that there's a
realistic spot for them unless Carolina
wants to trade out you usually don't see
trades within the division though so
then it would be Arizona maybe it eight
would want to trade but they want Derek
Brown so badly is what we're also
hearing so I don't know if that's a
candidate to but it might not even be CJ
Henderson it could be a drunk in LA or a
dick Brown when dimitrov was down there
at the Senior Bowl looking at these Jeff
on Kinlaw would be a homewrecker in that
defense thanks to Grady chair right the
last rumor for you guys Andrew Thomas
the left tackle from Georgia and that's
an important distinction that he played
left tackle over the last two years will
be the first tackle drafted in a top ten
pick especially top ten pick something
that we're hearing throughout this week
guys might nugget on this and I'll go to
you guys in just a bit for your cash or
trash on this we have a lot of tackles
Jedrek wills tristan warps both played
right tackle in college Makai Becton a
developmental player huge upside a lot
of potential but he's not NFL ready
right now we're seeing reports that the
NFL season can be shortened it could be
delayed there might not be Ricky
minicamp store might not be OTAs the
game readiness of Andrew Thomas a
two-year starter at left tackle in the
SEC that I think is why teams are
starting to lean that direction and you
look at these guys these other guys they
played right tackle Becton probably
should play right tackle to start in the
NFL I think Andrew Thomas is the most
Pro ready left tackle but I'm saying
trash on this one I think the upside of
guys like wills and worse it's still
there that I don't see Andrew Thomas in
the four in the top ten I like number
three tackle on this in this class I
would take him very high but I still
think he's behind wharfs and wills and I
don't think that's gonna land him in the
top ten I'm saying trash on this one
boys
I'm gonna go cash here guys and it kind
of goes back to the points Matt made
with Andrew Thomas I think when you look
at it he arrives at Georgia as a true
freshman he starts it right tackled the
entire season and he's a freshman
all-american that's extremely extremely
impressive to me then the next two years
he flips over to left tackle permanent
team captain in 2019 this guy is a pro
ready player from day one we are not
gonna have ot A's we are not gonna have
mini camp those things are gonna be done
as a virtual training session for
players and that's really not good
enough for most rookie offensive linemen
but Thomas is an exception now am i
sitting here saying he's gonna go
forward to the New York Giants I don't
believe that but 10 to the Cleveland
Browns would that surprise me
not at all when you look at Thomas this
is one of the guys one of the rare
instances where the pandemic actually
might really work in his favor for his
draft status that's a very good point
I'm gonna cash on this maybe not that
he's the OD one but I do think he'll be
a top-10 pick I would not roll out Dave
gentlemen just going crazy here I draft
an Andrew Thomas like we need a left
tackle we need a left tackle I know
we've been saying Isaiah Simmons I still
believe that'll be the pick but anything
Dave gentlemen does none of it surprises
me because all of it surprises I mean
we'll find out in the next week if he's
going to write well you hear about it
will definitely love all our Giants fans
absolutely do don't forget you can send
in your draft on draft questions just
leave a comment right here on the live
stream if you're watching this in the
Bleacher Report app and hopefully you
are because we're here every Monday
Wednesday Thursday now but we have a
little treat for you guys the newest
episode of call or nothing resign
William singing well I still think would
be the best edge rusher in this class
sorry K Sean Mike just another phone
ladies and gentlemen answering a video
chat from Zion Gleason John Moran I'm so
wore to guess we gotta find out who's
Ricky of the year after all this season
ain't over I play the fool dams in here
yeah I was thinking about streaming to K
while mumbling later no I'm playing oh
well another three for the presumptive
Rookie of the Year bro are you okay has
anyone on your team checked in on you
I've got the whole team here see is
Jonas Valentinus good that team there
oh wait you're in Jackson jr. what up
Dillon Brooks oh he's making up fake
people down JA basketball we'll come
back man but we got it take it easy is
that the NBA don't you think we should
still give out NBA Awards he has a point
what's Johnny's last name Chaka dumb
idiot boys we mustn't fight oh man why
when your didn't prepare me for stuff
like this Josh starts the second half he
goes around the screen are you okay no
one else can win Rookie of the Year if
I'm the only one playing I gotta bring
it help thanks I'm always by the fold
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by Jake from
State Farm
I'd like that right oh no no not Jake
from State Farm now former Georgia
quarterback that I'm projecting to be
selected in the second round of this
year's draft State Farm offers
incomparable home and auto insurance
along with amazing customer service
through the State Farm mobile app Jake
from offers a very high football IQ and
will stay tough in the pocket no matter
what no word on what types of home and
auto insurance he offers though guys
thanks to State Farm for supporting
stick to football
fun fact actually I'm State Farm he's
probably got the khakis on to Jeff
definitely is rockin some khakis and a
polo now it is time for our superstar
redraft because it is NFL redraft week
here at bleacher report
so we're imagining what could have been
like if my favorite player in the NFL
George Kittel had been drafted by the
Jacksonville Jaguars instead of my
beloved 49ers it's painful to think
about yeah I don't want to think about
some of these superstars my team has
been doing pretty good in the draft so I
read draft week though I'm looking
forward to maybe some better landing
spots for some of these superstars Billy
you're right your team has done well in
the NFL Draft the Kansas City Chiefs but
since we're redrafting things and we're
looking specifically I am at the 2017
NFL Draft when the Cleveland Browns had
the first pick
it took miles Garrett turned out pretty
well right but San Francisco 49ers owned
the number two pick in this draft mellow
and
ajan Super Bowl IV but instead of
quarterbacking the Kansas City Chiefs
Patrick mahomes is taking the sample
let's go 49ers to the sixth Lombardi
Trophy
if they hadn't traded the pick and it
just made the right selection Mahoney's
all across the Bay Area I would be
rocking a 15 right now that wouldn't be
Jerry Rice and Joe Montana behind us we
don't know Homes picture so what might
have been there with patty in San
Francisco and then Melo I know this
breaks your heart but the Texas Tech
legend just throwing you could've thrown
Michael Crabtree's it would have been
perfect no I'm not here for this at all
I get to live this Super Bowl L IV
champion we'd even have the right team
so I hate your redraft you sorry Connor
yeah I just had to rub that one in you
are up i man I absolutely love this look
at my homes just slinging it around in
college not much has changed the dude is
absolutely fearless and Matt I know
there's a little Homer and that one for
you I know you'd like to see good old
hat leading the Niners but I'm gonna go
here with the Green Bay Packers they
took this is just last year in 2019
Green Bay took Rashad Gary now I know he
was a little banged up as a rookie not
very productive and hopefully the
Packers do get more out of him going
forward but I'm gonna flip the switch
here a guy that teams waited on very
very long and that is DK Metcalfe who
had to wait till the end of the second
round to go to Seattle I understand
there was some medical concerns with DK
there was also some route development
concerns but what he does best we saw
with Seattle this year and I think we
would have saw it with Green Bank
God he's absolute beauty in that Packers
uniform that it looks great beautiful a
seamless transition right there with dk
this is a team as Aaron Rodgers gets
older that really needs a vertical
target down the field a big body guy we
know Davante Adams it's probably the
best route runner in all the football
great hands can do everything in you
know underneath an intermedia and he
could play you know down the field as
well but we know DK wins over the top
over and over again this would have made
life a lot easier on their older
quarterback and I think it's a reason
we're gonna see Green Bay target wide
receivers very early and often in this
year's draft
and like we've said before on the show
you look at who the Packers have
targeted at receiver it's those big
physical guy so I think that would does
make sense and it's another good fit I
won't sell out completely on the fact
that DK Metcalfe was one of the best
receivers in this class he shouldn't
have followed to the end of the second
round that's a great fit in Green Bay
just like it is in Seattle for him to go
there I'm gonna give you a running back
Christian McCaffrey who I think is the
best running back in the NFL right now
I'm gonna read draft him where he should
have went to the Jacksonville Jaguars
the Jaguars needed a running back and
they took Leonard fournette
in that draft you have Christian
McCaffrey who has completely changed in
office if Christian McCaffrey is still
with the Jaguars Nick Foles might still
be with the Jaguars help like bortles
might still be in with the Jaguars now
if he had a guy like this Christian
McCaffrey to throw to and hand the ball
off to first three years in the NFL he
has over 2500 yards rushing and 2500
yards receiving this guy's a beast he
doesn't get talked about enough at the
running back position I know he just got
his extension but this is a special
talent on Ed's son McCaffrey here he
could do everything catch the ball run
for speed redrafting him to the jaguars
the jaguars would be a static with this
pick he should own the Heisman Trophy
let's just also do that while we're at
it while we're fixing things he should
have won the Heisman Trophy then chunk
should have well I'm gonna stay with
2017 if my home's is off the board to
the Niners well the Bears still have the
number three pick in this draft they
don't trade up for mistake mr. Biscay
instead they draft another player who
should have won the Heisman deshaun
Watson from Clemson listen we all over
thought or at least I did all raise my
hand I overthought to shot Watson I
thought man this skinny quarterback
threw a lot of pigs out last year you
also do like 500 passes excuse me in
that final year at Clemson we forget
that this is a dude who was like Michael
Jordan beating Alabama when no one beat
Alabama back in the day so I apologize
to deshaun Watson
making it up for him getting away from
Bill O'Brien here you're welcome and you
get to go play for the Chicago Bears
whoo man he would have been such a great
fit in that offense I was gonna say who
loses in this spot deshaun Watson gets
the go to a legendary franchise like the
Bears away from Bill O'Brien who
just dismantling the Houston franchise
right now and Bears fans get a an
absolute star at quarterback so I love
that switch there Matt and I'm gonna go
back to wide receiver again for mine
with the Pittsburgh Steelers you guys
remember when they took Terrell Edmonds
in the first round and I think all of us
kind of looked at each other like whoa
that seems like a reach well let's fix
that mistake and go at Courtland Sutton
instead who ended up going in the second
round and now looks like a number one
wide receiver in Denver whether you have
juju and Courtland Sutton in the same
offense whatever quarterback comes in
after Big Ben would just be walking into
a great situation so I think for the
Steelers who are another historic
franchise but their first rounders have
been very hit-or-miss over the years a
little bit of a roller coaster they do
you know their best work what seems to
be on day two and beyond so fixing one
of these first-round mistakes and
Terrell Edmunds and getting another
playmaker for their offense would be a
lot of fun yeah you know I'm gonna stick
with the offensive side of the ball too
and I think I'm gonna piss off some of
our Ravens fans because I'm gonna
redraft with the NFL MVP from last year
I'm gonna take him at number 10 overall
I think you looked back at that draft
class you had the Baker Mayfield gents
and Arnold's Josh young I think a lot of
those teams are still kind of happy with
what they had at quarterback and a lot
of other teams didn't really need a
quarterback so I'm going to give him to
the Arizona Cardinals reason why I've
given him to the Cardinals just imagine
if they didn't take Josh Rosen if they
took Lamar Jackson at quarterback and
then we're in the same position next
year
you've landed yourself lamar jackson and
nick Bosa you're winning your Super Bowl
contender now yeah you're welcome
Arizona car he wouldn't even be so fun
and clip Kingsbury's office yes he's
just a more explosive Kyler Murray you
could have got Kingsbury to go there and
early you know earlier than he did when
he thought oh I can draft Kyler Murray I
can maybe stick with Josh Rosen but if
you have a little more Jackson in that
offense with everything spread out Larry
Fitzgerald to throw the ball to the
Cardinals have set up with himself up
very nicely and as you can see here guy
was already a cardinal once just taking
a I'm watching him in college those are
some of the best highlights we've seen
in recent memory and if you can't get
enough of those dial it all the way back
to when he was playing high school
ball in Florida it gets even more
ridiculous yeah absolutely one of the
one of the most fun players and failed
to watch and God putting him in
Kingsbury's John Harbaugh was done the
right thing but putting him in in
Kingsbury's offense would be getting
through the NFC is very important yeah
that Chiefs fans like get him out of
here get him out here it is time
speaking of the AFC we've got a gridiron
height supercut the best of Brady and
Belichick one of the most tragic
breakups in the history of the NFL you
see Tom is getting old and needs extra
protection
well then apply anti-aging organic I
black made from the ashes of Jimmy
Garoppolo contract extension Gisele was
wrong one day I will throw and that's
the day light reps for the normal
players meditation for Toms cold okay
thanks here's my special mind power
so the Patriots do not rebuild we reload
um coach are we cool now
oh hi coach have you met our terrible
backup yet hello I'm Thomas whoops
hahaha thank goodness for the Tuck rule
Thanos didn't go far enough I collected
all six coach we can finally retire now
you got to fill this one up
grow up so fast where's your foot my
congrats card I like to Hulu I'll do it
I'll move I don't think about you as
much as you think I do
boy the Jets were tough I don't know how
we did it but yo if you're after someone
Sofia doesn't become an athlete video
[Music]
absolutely heartbroken as a Tom Brady
friend and I'll see him in Tampa Bay it
still does not look right I know Connors
like smiling like this is a gem of
chance yeah we almost put a Brady photo
behind us today but didn't instead all
right we have three draft on draft
questions the hottest most fired
questions from the BR app which is where
you guys can submit these when we're
live on set here the first one from KOCO
nine is a great username what receivers
would be the best fit for the
Indianapolis Colts with the picks they
have reminder they traded 13 over L for
DeForest Buckner but they do have two
picks in the second round guys I'm a big
Michael Pittman jr. fan from USC I know
we've had him going you know in the 40s
and 50s but Michael Pittman jr. if he's
there I think he's like the fifth or six
best receiver in this class I know
there's some love for Denzel Mims KJ
handler Jalen Drager I want the size and
play making ability of Michael Pittman
yeah I was gonna go with size and play
making ability to but I think it picked
34 overall you still have t Higgins
probably on the board there we did our
over unders on Monday I think that we
can see a receiver fall in this draft
and people say I don't want the fifth
best receiver not in the first round and
that puts him right there in that spot
to be taken by the Colts or you know
another guy that has not had a great
process but kind of fits the mold of
that Parris Campbell type receiver his
low viscous che know I don't know if
maybe they want both of those guys or
maybe they weren't happy with what they
had with Campbell but I think that he is
athletic enough that he could still be
in play in the second round yeah I love
the options you guys mentioned and I'll
move it to round number three or four
then I think if you're looking for a
possession guy you're gonna look at van
Jefferson maybe Brian Edwards to get
some more size yeah Edwards kind of
feels like the you know the knockoff
version maybe of t Higgins in this class
or Denzel Mims he doesn't necessarily
have the best athleticism but a guy that
catches everything around him so and you
bring up a great point mellow Parris
Campbell what are their expectations of
him in year
- after a lost rookie season because if
they feel good about what he can bring
to the table as a speed element then
you're gonna take guys off the board
like KJ hammer
jaylen rhaegar those guys that are speed
guys maybe they're not gonna look at
them as much and go for more size later
on in this draft yeah I think this that
really intriguing team I do they go
quarterback somewhere they have whole
staffel pass rushers as well I can
question for PES 101 one do the Patriots
draft a quarterback this year or stick
with Jarret Stidham if they draft a
quarterback who do they choose and what
round I'm just gonna turn to Melo and
lay take it away
don't worry answer absolutely not they
do not draft a quarterback because they
have the quarterback of the future I
know that he didn't get a lot of reps
behind Tom Brady the greatest
quarterback of all time but he's still a
damn good quarterback with jarred
Stidham this is a guy who was number one
quarterback for me I don't know if I've
said that Leverett but I do think that
we saw enough with him he fell to the
fourth round I don't care you can give
me crap for it I still think he's a good
quarterback he sat behind Brady for a
year he looked really good in the
preseason which doesn't mean much but I
don't think they put themselves in a
position this offseason to go after a
quarterback and I think Belichick still
doesn't want to eat that humble pie and
say oh I was so reliant on Tom Brady he
was so good he was everything I think
he's gonna roll out with a rookie this
year and Brian Hoyer backing him up and
say hey look Tampa Bay I can still win
with this young quarterback over here
there's not nearly the quarterbacking
work taba Bay it'll never ever sound
good stop trying to make it known Tom
Brady I'm 50/50 on this one Bill
Belichick has a little Gruden in him
where he's has an obsession with
collecting these day three quarterbacks
over and over again I think three of
them are actually coaches in the NFL
right now if you searched that far back
so I could see them taking a Jake Fromm
if he's there in round three just
because high IQ guy doesn't turn the
ball over all of those things that New
England is kind of notorious for loving
but they don't have to take one because
you got Hoyer backing up Stidham going
into the year so I don't think they'll
be over aggressive it would shock me if
you know they've moved up to 15 or
whatever it is for a guy like Jordan
love
I think they'll sit there and be very
patient in this class the thing that
stands out to me
that what they didn't do it's not so
much what they have done it so they
didn't do they didn't go after you know
any of the quarterbacks who are
available kept hearing like oh maybe
they'll be maybe they'll go after XYZ
Marcus Mariota whoever it might be they
didn't go after any quarterbacks the
only player they've added is Brian Hoyer
someone who's like a second coach for me
he's a backing up Josh McDaniels based
Asha quarterbacks coach that to me
points to them liking Jared Stidham they
have been connected to a lot of
quarterbacks they were connected to a
lot of quarterbacks in the last two
years and Stidham apparently was their
guy so I don't think they draft a
quarterback I mean it would be cool to
see them go Anthony Gordon in the sixth
round just to give someone like that a
shot at Cole McDonald in seventh round
but I would be very very surprised if
they do pick one that early all right we
got one more question in here it looks
like maybe to Connor Rodgers fan cutter
I buried him in the Bleacher Report app
chance this and they say that this has
to be you I'm convinced this is actually
good you put this in right putting
comments in while bellows on camera come
on Bay what are the chances tompa bay
trades up and takes Andrew Thomas from
under the Jets nose this is actually
don't make a burner account just ask
recipe texts man yeah and they're coming
up with scenarios that would just crush
me this is not how the dice at all okay
might be right when you look at it
though there is a chance there's a
chance Tampa Bay comes up in this trap
or a tackle I'm not gonna lie to you
guys I'm a little surprised that they
haven't reached out to a better an
option may be like Jason Peters or
somebody that you know can come in and
give you a year protecting Tom Brady
that alone tells me that Tampa feels
good where they're sitting at to get a
tackle whether they like Josh Jones or
Austin Jackson more than not just us but
the general you know draft consensus
values them more in the 18 to 30 range
or they are gonna be super aggressive
and go hey we got a two-year window
right now all that capital in the future
throw it in the trash it goes back to
the cash or trash segment we're going to
jump the Browns the
Jetts they need tackles I'm very very
nervous and curious to see what Tampa
does I think there's a possibility but
again it goes back to the draft capital
argument of you signed 43 year-old Tom
Brady do you really want a mortgage that
many picks to get a tackle win like they
feel decent about their left tackle so
yeah you would like to obviously you
liked it better but they feel like
they're ok with Donovan Smith so I don't
I don't see them making that aggressive
of a move
I think anything they would rather have
that second round pick to get another
running back someone to help Brady
because Ronald Jones has been very very
inconsistent to date in his career last
question from our guy Jared brown and
this is one for all our fantasy football
fans who are some day three offensive
skill guys that can make an impact as a
rookie so you're talking like deep
sleeper 14th round there's two beers
left in the fridge and it's time to make
some picks in your fantasy team you can
remember these names I'm gonna cheat and
go first Lynn Bowden and Adam Trotman I
think both players Bowden it's just
gonna get touches I think we see him
helping the return game a player we've
had on this show before we all love the
tenacity the fire that he plays with and
our guy Adam Kramer has a killer story
about him that you can see in the be our
app so I think Lynn Bowden and if
trapping goes he might be a second or
third Titan off the board I think he's
gonna break that mold of being a super
productive rookie tight end and I think
I'll stick with the tight in and then I
want to give you one receiver Harrison
Brian FAU I think that he's a really
good receiver he played out a low level
but when you watch him against guys like
Ohio State he had some of his biggest
games with zero help from the offensive
line and almost nothing from the
quarterback I think that fantasy
football is a lot about production and
you can get those production numbers
from a guy who's gonna be a red zone
target and then what about a late
receiver a guy who's probably gonna be
drafted in the sixth round I don't know
maybe somebody out of Minnesota maybe
Tyler Wow Wow for those that don't know
just look at Matt's Twitter history with
Tyler and Johnson to see what our sake
was a note about Minnesota he was
productive in Minnesota when he wasn't
dropping the ball I'll give you that the
brother rivalry is on Episode two it
took a second episode to get us here
alright I'm not gonna go into the
tight-end class because I think it
stinks so I'm gonna start with the
runningback class and a guy that didn't
even play running back in college but
he's gonna make the switch that's
Antonio Gibson from Memphis I think he
started only one game at running back
and he looked like a top 5 runner in
this class that's out talented he is so
you're looking for a day 3 guy that can
play receiver can play running back and
was an electric kick returner I like
what Gibson Gibson can do in the right
role and we saw that with another
Memphis guy in Tony Pollard last year in
Dallas so Gibson you know for three 962
221 pounds he's got it and then you look
at wide receiver I'm gonna go with two
guys that just aren't very flashy but
might find a you know a roll on offense
is a wide receiver three these two guys
catch everything that's KJ Hill and
Isaiah Hodgins they are not going to go
in the first three rounds because
neither run extremely extremely well and
they just don't have the flash as the
top wide receivers but they have two of
the best drop rates in the entire
country and I think they're Pro ready
high IQ receivers that'll get on the
field early especially in PPR formats I
was really expecting mellow to say Devon
Duvernay you know this guy dropped one
passing college really fast no he goes
someone else alright that is our show
find us on Twitter at stick to football
find us in the Bleacher Report app you
can subscribe to the stick to football
stream if you want to keep up with the
mailbags this shows the podcasts that
we're doing and you can still listen to
those podcasts three times a week
wherever you get your shows Apple pod
stitch or Spotify a stick to football at
NFL draft Scalia is at mellow and act
Conner
Jay Rogers there goes my voice so there
goes our show we will see you guys right
back here tomorrow at 5 p.m. Eastern
Time on stick to football
[Music]
[Music]